Now I want to take some time to
show you how to use variables and
constants in a playground.
I've gone ahead and
opened this empty playground, and
we'll get started by
declaring some variables.
We know to create a variable that we
need to use something like the following
syntax; we have the keyword var,
then some name for
the variable and its value.
For example,
I'll create this variable called
myJerseyNumber with a value of five.
This creates, or declares a variable
with the name myJerseyNumber and
when we write this code Swift works
behind the scenes in a furze that my
jersey numbers type is an integer,
because five is an integer.
And we can check this if we
hold down the option key and
go up to the variable name and
we click it.
We can see that it's been
declared as an INT value.
When Swift automatically infers
the type of the variable,
in this case the INT,
we call this inferred typing.
So let's do another example.
So we will create this variable
called myCoolVariable and
give it a value of a and double quotes.
So if you've created a variable like
this before where you use the double
quotes, you may already know what Swift
may infer this to be, but we can check.
And it looks like Swift has
interpreted this as a string variable.
So myCoolVariable contains a string and
that makes sense,
that's what this double quotes mean,
that means a string.
But this string is just one character,.
What if we wanted the variable to be
of character type because it represents
a single character,
instead of a string type which can
represent multiple characters?
Is there a way that we
can help Swift do this?
Actually there is, and here's how.
We'll modify our
variable declaration and
add a colon after the name and
then specify the type that we want.
So this is a slightly different
syntax than we saw before, but
it removes the need for
Swift to guess the variables type
because we're explicitly stating it.
In this case we want
to be a character and
when we take the guesswork out of typing
for Swift, we call this explicit typing.
And if I use the option click, we can
see that this is now a character and
no longer a string.
In general, Swift does a great job at
inferring the types of our variables so
explicit typing is
usually not necessary.
However, in some cases, like this one,
you want to use explicit typing so
that the compiler knows exactly what
type you intend for the variable.